je suis en guerre depuis 12 ans
[Applaudissements]
le médiator plus de deux millions de
personnes en ont pris depuis 1976 et pas
seulement des diabétiques
beaucoup l'ont utilisé aussi comme
simple coupe-faim
nous avons observé entre 2003 et 2009 au
chu de brest
une vingtaine de personnes très
sévèrement atteintes par l'exposition
enfin que nous avons relié à
l'exposition aux médicaments et parmi
ces personnes nous avons trois personnes
qui sont décédées
[Musique]
lorsque j'ai vu que le retrait du
médiator se faisait en catimini sans
avertir qui que ce soit j'ai compris
qu'il fallait aller plus loin et
dénoncer ça publiquement et donc je me
suivait la seule façon c'est de publier
un témoignage parfaitement factuelle
parfaitement chronologique
des laboratoires servier qui
fabriquaient est commercialisé
l'adjuvant jusqu'en novembre dernier
demande le retrait de la mention combien
de morts cette mention combien de morts
ne correspond pas à une réalité
scientifique avéré poser la question
combien de morts et faire le bilan de
cette pharmacovigilance ça ne me
paraissait pas attaquable et pourtant le
juge l'a condamnée et ça ça a été un
coup de tonnerre
vraiment honnêtement je m'y attendais
pas
[Musique]
là où il ya eu enfin on a franchi le mur
de la communication c'est en novembre
2010 l' agence du médicament a dû
reconnaître dans une conférence de
presse historique que le bilan du
médiator était d'au moins 500 morts
et là c'est l'explosion médiatique dans
la foulée xavier bertrand qui venait
d'être nommé ministre de la santé prend
le problème à bras le corps il est le
premier responsable de santé publique
qui a pensé à la vie des gens le premier
c'est un moment que je n'oublierai
jamais à tous ceux qui ont pris du
médiator c'est de prendre contact et de
consulter leur médecin leur médecin
traitant
vous avez lu le volume que cela
représente de les mettre en ligne
en six semaines un rapport de l'igas
action exceptionnelle a permis de
comprendre effectivement que c'était une
histoire absolument insensé avec une
dérive totale de l' agence du médicament
et une criminalité hors norme
organiser des laboratoires servier
la sphère du médiator pour moi c'est
l'empreinte d'un combat et même d'une
guerre
des gens sont morts des gens continuent
à mourir et on a affaire à des
adversaires extrêmement difficile à
combattre
très puissant nous sommes en guerre
[Musique]